I remember when I had my truck I uh like
I had the center console thing and um
you know when when you're in a certain
age where you cannot do certain things
at home you do things in your car oh
yeah stocking sex people yeah
[Music]
so uh in the interests of always
bringing out people's
um I think their most interesting sides
Bart is kind of our resident car guy oh
okay and Bart are you familiar with the
Audi A6 that's very familiar wait he's
our resident car guy not him he's the
car guy I think Ryan's the car guy but I
think I'm the new car guy maybe I only
know I only know old buckets I'm
familiar with the Audi A6 is the sedan
if you ever need a scooter guy yeah if
you need a miatica just saw Raiders
sometimes you need to be honest what
about the Audi A6 the Audi A6 uh and S6
are being recalled really for a [__]
wild reason whoa really they're blowing
up the brakes don't work if you if you
have a back seat spill it could cut the
engine's power shut the [__] up what the
[__] just spilling like [__] soda or
something yeah there's what there's a
Gateway control module that could shut
down if there's a liquid spilled car's
rear seating area because that's where
the engine is that is a wild recall
right they like recall all these cars
and they put a tarp under the seat and
that's it yeah well that's what they're
planning on doing actually honestly not
a tarp but they're gonna called it
protective covered over the area
affected oh my God first of all I in the
early 2000s loved Audis I thought they
were [__] sexy sounded good they
don't like Audis no more because uh when
I remember finally being like you know
I'm gonna go get an Audi everyone around
me was like worse maintenance it's just
the worst like of all the especially for
a luxury like German luxury car type
stuff yeah like you're always pulling
that [__] in they're always having fixed
stuff so it's like that's why I just
keep it for a couple years
all right baller yeah it's called
leasing you know what's crazy is the A6
so that's like their base model right
their Supercar the RS6 so and the Audi
series every car is they have like um
kind of like a Beamers they have like
the three series and they have like the
M3
they have their S Series like the S6 and
then they have RS6 which is like a super
super car so it'd be almost like a M3
like GT version or whatever
that car wasn't even gonna be released
in America but it was such it was a
station wagon but it was so sick that
everyone wanted it that they ended up
bringing it over here but it sucks that
now that they brought it over here
there's uh recalls on it yeah man they
recall do you think it's worldwide
recalls or just the American market so
far it's just 50 000 vehicles that they
sold every
country has their own regulation so it
could just be this one yeah because
sometimes I have to make cars to that
country so if the country's like this is
how you have to make a car they might
have to like oh I guess we'll have to
rewire it this way and that could be
what caused the problems wildest part is
it includes 2019 to 2022 models oh [__]
it's like oh it's it's been a problem
with their manufacturing for a while and
it's a brand new model that they just
introduced because they only had an A5
and A7 they just dropped A6 but but
you're not the cargo
she knows about the tire business he
knows about the smog business you know
he knows about every industry I don't
know about nothing he knows HVAC
Bart how do you rate Audis versus you
know say your car he had an Audi yeah do
you like it I loved it it's a [__] I
had an RS7 it was uh it would be
considered like a Supercar of a sedan
and it was I think like it came with 600
horses I chipped it and I put a
cat-backed exhaust on it so now I was
pushing 700 and those I I've used that
as an excuse to be my dad car
I was also my dad car because I had a
Porsche I was like I got a kid now I
can't be driving on the two doors I need
four doors so I got that car and I was
pretty [__] cool guy car was 700
horsepower dude you know what it's
[__] crazy so you're like at 80 right
80 miles an hour which is like people
call that fast
um because you're not really supposed to
drive that fast on the freeway but when
you go from 80 when I slam it literally
in a second I'm at 120. why don't you
just go
like that it's crazy to it almost seems
like there's like some [__] like
German engineer like can you do your
voice I'll do that for you I'll do that
for you yeah
oh [__] would you like to go faster
damn that's pretty tight that's [__]
tight your Tesla basically does that too
yeah how's that reaching a Tesla doesn't
do that at the top end at the bottom
because that's 460. that it's torquey
right so it pulls like from Tesla won't
go from 80 to 120 and like not in a
second wow
but it goes from zero to like [__] 80
and pretty fast yeah the low ends but
also my car used to scream which is
[__] it was loud yeah you turned it
on like it sounds like a [__] like
fighter jet I [__] hate you guys
because you drive up my [__] Street
yeah and it gives me a goddamn heart
attack
my call is silent
you guys like me that [__] was a fighter
jet my car was silent but then I ended
up just driving the truck around because
it's like you know when you have too
many things done and it's like this
hobby type thing and then like [__]
you pop a tire you like scrape a wheel
you feel so bad because it's like oh I
put so much into this thing and so I
said driving the truck around there's
like months where I don't even drive it
and I'm like guys and I'm selling it
but I would get another one now because
my roads smart my roads are smooth now
you know I'm talking about potholes in
Vegas why is that I don't have to say
maybe just property taxes better
utilized maybe I don't know
won't mean nothing if you're driving in
the red
I wish you could have got too late I
wish you could have cut to me this
morning like just in the middle of my
Uber ride I'm like there's [__] I got
a Blake it's [__] sick I'm like
telling the [__] guy I can move to
Vegas it's the best dude I'll just drive
there now
he's like you do Uber out there easy
dude he's like how much is gas out there
I'm like four bucks he's like holy [__]
yeah have you guys had to deal with uh
had to ever deal with like a recall for
your car yep and I didn't even take it
in what was it it was something Toyota
with the [__] airbag one it was some
[__] yeah we're always airbag recalls
yeah Geo had a Honda Accord that had it
it was like a big range it was like 2004
to 2008 yeah
I had a with my Jeep Grand Cherokee I
got this random recall afterwards this
and I only found out about it because it
happened to my car oh the headrest right
you know like literally just the thing
that you can [__] take out with the
two spokes right yeah for whatever the
[__] reason uh could explode what the
[__] like is there a airbag in there not
like there's a spring though oh what the
[__] and then so I'm driving one day
right and I'm like maybe going over like
one of those like slower speed bumps and
Nina's in the car and then this thing
[__] just donkey punches her in the
back of the head she like yells at me
and I'm like what the [__] she's like
mad at me for a second because
somebody's just like she thought you
went like that because she got like
socked in the head and then we looked
back at the thing and literally it looks
like one of those like like a Jack In
The Box was just being spun the whole
time and then out of nowhere it's just
like and the front thing is just
sticking out and you look at it and the
Springs like stuck out and the plastic's
broken okay can you sue no it wasn't
like overly like painful but it just
happened that I took it into gym they're
like I was like I don't know if you guys
have seen this before but this headrest
and the guy's like oh yeah that type of
another field and we had a recall about
and I was like you guys just have
headrests that are just donkey punching
people he's like mostly babies yeah
people that deserve it and then it took
me like three months to get a new one it
was [__] crazy it took [__]
forever to get a new headrest so it
needed to just be like riding the
passenger seat like this oh so you're
just driving with no headrest no Aura
was there but it was just like
protruding oh dude that's [__] weird
that's a lame of [__] I don't you ever
remember the last time I used a headrest
do his dressing right now on the show no
like this
weird Flex I remember when I had my
truck I uh like I had the center console
thing and um you know when when you're
in a certain age where you cannot do
certain things at home you do things in
your car oh yeah stalking sex people
yeah sex sex [__] in my car
and then the dope is sex dope is section
and then the center console just [__]
broke off
completely broke up right so then you
know I have my mom in the car giving her
a ride to her her work um in your sex
car in my sex car yeah I know I didn't
[__] my mom yeah you pervert don't say I
[__] my mom because it's because I said
that
so then um my mom's like Oh my God
Stephen what happened to your thing and
I I was just like you didn't say oh I
had sex I was laying pipe Ma I'm saying
that so I was like I was like oh like I
was cracking my back and I was holding
it and just like
such an outline cracking my back like
this the whole time dude she bought it
she bought it he puts his foot up on the
[__] footrest I step on it I'm
stepping on her neck
and then I accidentally stepped on the
center console you guys know how that
goes to get more leverage dude
what a [__] funny ass thing let's cry
crack my back
oh okay
[Music]
foreign